Then I ran, ran, ran, ran, and the
town was peaceful. I can't do anything with this. Hey, I'm
disqualified as a professional.
[Music]
Stop. [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
If you were a strong hero, you'd call me out.  Stop
[Music]
Look, I
'll erase you. That punch won't kill me. I'll be the
root of all the rumors of fear here. The
bald ones will come rushing in. They'll fly away in the atmosphere and
destroy the beacon.  I guess that means I haven't changed, or
if I make one mistake, I'll end up like him.Emergency
evacuation warning: 21 minutes left until the giant meteorite hits. Please evacuate.If
the outcome doesn't change, I'll be the
same.  I'm going to use all my strength, and
this is my grave.
Brother, I'm going to leave it to you. It's fallen on my street. Well
then, I'm going to make it a little bit stronger. You
guys can't do it without me.
This is the end. I'm going to take care of
this incident."  If we solve this problem, the group's stock will rise even more. It's too
bad. It's hard to see the hellish storm. It's
hard to see the value of existence. There's
no point in running away. There's no value in living. Death can't bridge the gap. I'll continue to refine myself.
Tomorrow, I'll be stronger than I am today.  Now,
I'm just here to experiment with weapons. This is my
strongest power. It's weak, weak, too much. I've waited, I've
waited. I'm the strongest force in the house of evolution. Can I
keep up with this speed? What am I doing?
Da
[Music]
[Applause]
H
[Music]